[Music]
so I don't generally do spoiler reviews
for video games in fact I never have in
the past but after beating the last of
us last week I could not stop thinking
about that game I haven't been able to
stop thinking about it and I realized
that my original review just didn't do
the game justice despite the fact that I
gave the game a 10 out of 10 I have so
many things I wanted to talk to you guys
about but I couldn't in their view
because I didn't want to spoil the
experience for you I'm gonna tell you
guys my favorite things about the Last
of Us things I loved about it things I'd
love to see if they ever made a second
one and hopefully entertain you at the
same time so I guess the most impressive
thing about this game to me was how much
I was into the characters just how much
I cared about Joel and Ellie I've been
thinking for the past couple days and I
really don't think I've played a better
video game since Metal Gear Solid 4 yeah
I don't think I have Metal Gear Solid 4
is the last game I can remember being
that invested emotionally in a game from
the first opening scene of this game and
you're walking around as Joel's daughter
and you're playing as her and you're not
sure where your father is
I was so into the game in fact I was
like wait a second are you gonna play as
her for a really long time I was I was
curious how they were gonna do it
because I stayed away from all trailers
or clips about this game and I did that
on purpose actually because I heard so
many things going in that I wanted to
keep myself as sheltered from it as
possible so I could have the full
experience I'm so glad that I did I have
not felt this excited about a video game
since I originally picked up Metal Gear
Solid for the first time back in the
late 90s and beat that game and the very
next day went back and beat again all in
one day in one sitting like that's how
excited I was about Metal Gear Solid
that was the first game in fact it's
right there Mel you're Solid was the
first game I ever played that told me
that games could be something other than
just fun games can be art and ever since
then I've been really into him even more
so than when I was a kid and I just I
loved my starfox 64 and I love my donkey
kong country but until Metal Gear Solid
came along I never really realized that
games could be art The Last of Us is a
game that gets you so into the
characters through fantastic motion
capture work amazing voice acting and
the most realistic portrayal of people
in a video game that I've ever seen I
mean the way their eyes moved the way
their mouths move the body languages
emotions everything feels so real I
watched Ellie and I watched Joel and I
was absolute
we convinced those were too real people
even though I knew I was playing a game
and something that was very jarring at
first but I eventually really liked was
as a situation came to such an emotional
height that you weren't exactly sure
where else these characters could go it
would generally cut and move on to the
next season and where at first I thought
that was a little lazy like they were
straying away from how we're going to
explain how these characters get back
from this how they're gonna get up from
these situations now that they're so low
it would like cut to fall and it would
cut to winter then it would cut to
spring and I was always wondering like
what happened in that interim but I came
to love how you would see that the
characters had matured and grown even
more over the past couple months that
you're now cutting ahead and you can see
how that situation actually affected
them and brought those two people closer
and really revitalized that
father-daughter like relationship that
they eventually have towards the end of
the game I already told you how much I
loved the controls and how everything
felt so perfect and flawless the bow and
arrow my gun is hitting a guy with a bow
and arrow was like the ultimate ultimate
satisfaction I got to tell you guys
about one of the most satisfying game
experiences I've ever had I have not
felt this much adrenaline since I
defeated the end the sniper there's a
section towards the end of the game
where you have to get to Ellie who's on
the operating table and there's this
long corridor filled with like ten
guards who have the power of Zeus or
something I shot these guys like ten
times each and they still did not go
down in the head I don't know what they
were doing they were like all hyped up
on something these Firefly people were
insane they were so strong you could not
even see my health it was like the
little hairline red health I was just
about to die I had like no bullets left
all I had was like two arrows and there
was one guard left and I had used each
remaining bullet and I shot this guy
probably like five times and he was
still crouching there behind this little
corridor waiting for me and I just sat
there for like five minutes just
watching how he moved and everything
because the AI in this game is fantastic
they're very unpredictable and finally I
stood up stretched my bow out as fast as
I possibly could he immediately sees me
comes up with his rifle fires one shot I
fire one bow the bullet goes by my head
my bow hits him I drop the controller
and I was like yes I was like oh my god
because that was a really hard section
where there was like no checkpoint you
had to feel like every single guy in
that section to be able to get past it
you couldn't like defeat like eight out
of ten of them
and hope that maybe if you got killed
you could restart where you were no and
that's one of the things I loved about
this game because well that game play
was extremely exciting and well the
aspect of the game where you have the
controls and the crouching and all that
worked so well the reason I loved it so
much besides that was how interested I
was in those characters and how much I
wanted Joel to be okay and how much I
wanted to get to Ellie because dough
really can't die and so the most
cinematic experience I've had with the
game in years and the Last of Us really
truly is a masterpiece I think of modern
video games now for me the most exciting
sequence that I did not expect was when
Joel gets really badly injured he gets
that rusty pipe or whatever through his
lower abdomen and then you actually had
to play as Ellie for a while and when
you took control of Ellie and you
realized oh my god I'm about to start
playing as Ellie I was so excited
because you watch her character mature
so much to turn to this awesome little
badass and when you were hiding in that
restaurant from that really evil guy who
runs that group of cannibals also you
get to go on a freaking horse you to
ride horses in this game and every
little aspect of the control is so good
I gotta say there's only one thing in
this game that I felt the control was
more difficult than it should be and
that was swimming swimming or diving or
going underwater seemed a little bit too
hard sometimes I would get stuck in the
areas I mean if that's the only thing I
can think of to say is wrong with this
game I mean with a game this expansive
and large that's pretty impressive
has the game drew do a finale and you
got so close to these characters I was
thinking please just don't die I really
honestly I that's how it is with me see
some movies where a character dies it's
a main character and it feels very
tragic and it works for the movie and
you're like okay I understand that I
cared about these characters in this
game so much I took Ellie hunting for
deer you know I watched Joel learn how
to care about a young girl again I felt
so connected to these fictional
characters that I wanted them to survive
so much and I think the creator's knew
that you were gonna feel that towards
the end of the game because when Ellie
is on the operating table and you have
to run through these hallways as fast as
possible I swear I think I got shot and
killed so many times because I was just
running out in front of all these guards
like Here I am because I was like no
Ellie don't die and I was running
through the hallways and I was like I
probably should avoid some of these
guards she's not gonna die I can crouch
and wait there wasn't like a time or
anything Ellie will die in five minutes
that would been really stupid and I got
a few questions on Facebook and Twitter
what did I think of the ending good I
think it worked I think it was fantastic
because it was perfect for each one of
these characters you find out that le
the only way to get the Cure from her is
to kill her because this cure it's
attached her brain what not to extract
the needed stuff to create a vaccine for
this plague would kill Ellie Joel can't
have that so he rescues her she's
unconscious when she wakes up Joel tells
her they found the fireflies while she
was unconscious there was a whole bunch
of other people who had similar things
just like her they were all immune just
like her and nothing happened they
couldn't get a cure out of it it just
wasn't gonna work so now they're on
their way to do whatever they're gonna
try to live and survive she eventually
asked him hey is everything you told me
true and he says I swear it's true and
she goes okay
and then it ends I thought that was
perfect I absolutely thought that was
perfect because you truly saw the pain
that Joel had with no one he was able to
feel like he had a daughter again and he
just couldn't give that up there was no
way he could give that up he is willing
to live in a world infested with disease
maniacs as long as he can have this girl
with him and I find that so poetic and
it's just beautiful and I truly truly
hope that we get a second game this is
the most attached I felt a game
character since the Metal Gear Solid
games I love The Last of Us as I said in
my original review I'm gonna give it a
ten out of ten it's a masterpiece of
gaming in my opinion and I truly hope
you guys check it out sometime if you
get a chance I can't recommend it more
never skip the cutscenes don't do that
you'll miss so much about this game
everything about the game was so well
crafted the music was so subtle and
low-key but when it needed to be like
when you were carrying Ellie through the
hallways she was unconscious and their
regards everywhere and you were actually
just literally walking out right in
front of them and they were shooting at
you and you just had to keep going and
going and the music was like oh my palms
were all sweaty and I was just getting
so into it I know it's funny because I
am a gamer and I grew up being a gamer I
love movies obviously you guys know that
but when a game comes along that feels
like it combines a movie and a game it's
like something else for me it's like a
euphoria that I can't even describe when
a game feels that cinematic but also has
masterful control and story elements
kind of like heavy rain terrific
terrific game also so what did you guys
think The Last of Us if you did play it
I really appreciate you guys watching
second review I I may do more spoiler
reviews for games if I feel they warrant
them because this is the only game I've
played so far this year that I feel
warrants more discussion because of this
story and the underlying elements of the
whole game also I just want to clear
something up a lot of people have been
like hey dude did you play BioShock
Infinite
have you played the Uncharted games yeah
I actually did play BioShock Infinite
I just played it really late and I
didn't get a chance to review it early
and didn't really seem like it was
necessary but it was really good and yes
I have played uncharted I've played
uncharted I know everyone's like dude
you love being a Jones right you should
play Uncharted I have good games good
games I hope you guys have a good day
and thanks as always for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck my next
[Music]